mira yo creo que el principal desafío
que tiene un presidente que asume con la
edad que tiene sin una carrera
profesional y sin más experiencia
laboral que la cámara de diputados es
gobernar en el último periodo del
gobierno de piñera sin duda hace un
periodo muy difícil desde el punto de
vista de la gobernabilidad tanto en el
norte del país como en el sur del país y
el deterioro de la convivencia social
entre los chilenos es un tema que
realmente en angustia a todas las
mujeres particularmente a las que somos
madres pero también a los jóvenes a los
niños que están hoy día tal como lo
mencionara el presidente boris en una
situación bastante met
está también entonces yo creo que el
desafío es precisamente gobernar él se
ha rodeado de un equipo con una pujanza
poco vista en las últimas décadas no
gente claramente con una beca menos en
el cuerpo en todo el gabinete
se espera mucho de su gobierno del
gobierno de bobby verdad quizás una luna
de miel corta si ustedes quieren hay
mucha expectativa en torno a este
gobierno y él se ha encargado de
alimentarla también entonces frente a
desafíos múltiples
me parece a mí que el gran dilema de él
es cómo va a echar a andar esta
maquinaria lo antes posible para
gobernar con no con eficiencia que es el
discurso de piñera sino que con corazón
pero también con inteligencia este país
no es fácil de gobernar hoy día somos
casi 19 millones de habitantes 16
regiones tenemos el 8 por ciento de
población indígena solamente pero
tenemos un 12 por ciento inmigrante este
es un país que es difícil de coordinar
por su geografía y sin duda final los
planteamientos que resumía tu colega al
respecto del discurso son totales
efectivamente sobre totales porque
porque la dimensión del desafío hoy día
en un mundo incierto
volátil líquido si tú quieres y hace que
las cuestiones se tengan que mirar de
forma acelerada yo tengo esperanza
de que efectivamente el gabinete que ha
puesto sea óptimo sin embargo veo
algunas sombras y estas sombras tienen
que ver con la inexperiencia es de
esperar es desde este desear y tenemos
toda la fe de que al gobierno le vaya
bien en ese sentido pero es sin duda
gobernar lo que le va a ser más difícil
el imponerse el tener en el que la gente
no sólo lo siga y entienda este cambio
de discurso sino que además
funcione el país porque bien gran parte
de él un tanto aletargado y oxidado en
las últimas dos administraciones porque
esto no tiene solamente que ver con el
gobierno definida ya yo creo que dejaste
hace una década y posteridad el
terremoto del 2010 es que tenemos
dificultades en la gobernabilidad en la
convivencia social
en
cambiar el switch y hacer el país más
más amable más vivible